the climate activist group extinction
rebellion has kicked off worldwide
protests warning of an environmental
apocalypse here in Berlin protesters
gathered at dawn to block streets in the
city's center over the next two weeks
civil disobedience actions where
protesters attempt to peacefully
paralyze cities are planned in 60 cities
around the world protesters want
greenhouse gas emissions to be cut to
zero by 2025 we now go to our
correspondence in London and here in
Berlin let's start with Beckett Moss who
is joining us there on the streets of
London I understand that protests are
just getting underway there what's the
situation on the streets well I'm here
in the government district and London
and protesters are blocking several
sites in and around the government
district they are trying to block it
what you can see going on behind me is
that protesters have been trying to put
up tents and other structures and police
have then calmly taken the same
structures down so it seems a little bit
like a back end force
so what protesters try to put things up
and then again police put things down
I've also seen one young gentleman
arrested and there's been media reports
that these there have been so far 21
arrests all over London now the last
time there was a big protest in London
was at the beginning of the summer
before the summer and police have not
been very heavy-handed however today
I've seen here in London a lot of police
on the streets and they have also
announced that they will arrest people
so the question is how many protesters
will want to be arrested or will will be
willing to be arrested but it seems that
it's just going underway and it's a bit
lava you know a bit of a battle but a
very peaceful battle at the moment
between what the protesters won and what
the police want okay a number of arrests
already in Berlin or rather in London
and a massive police presence so Simon
young is our correspondents on the
street here in Berlin Simon what are you
seeing there
Terry I'm standing here at the victory
monument that's not far from the
Brandenburg Gate in the center of Berlin
it's a key traffic roundabout and the
protest is several hundred of them
who've been here since the early morning
have managed to block traffic from
passing through here I can show you the
scene it's an empty street normally this
would be full of heavy traffic buses
lorries and cars at this time of day
today there's nothing and also the
atmosphere here rather different to what
bigots describing in London there have
been no arrests the police are holding
off they're taking a watch and watch and
wait approach and the atmosphere among
protesters is peaceful nonviolent that
people are singing songs and chanting
slogans and you probably see behind me
there they've been building this sort of
Noah's Ark that they've been painting
pink that's going to be the central
focus of the demonstrations here today
now these protests have been anticipated
of course we caught up with some of the
activists in the German capital here as
they made their preparations for this
week of protests let's take a look this
is how environmental activists from
extinction rebellion are preparing for
the protests one of them is 28 year old
Luca Alice the activists undergo
training and how to behave when blocking
a road and when being removed by the
police
our Liz and the other activists are
demanding more climate protection action
from governments that includes a call
for a climate emergency to be declared
to make their point activists want a
paralyzed transport in Berlin Luka Alice
says she's willing to be arrested if
necessary this is the only way to show
how serious we are it's not sufficient
anymore to simply wave flags and
demonstrate we need to make clear how
bad the situation is
and I think it will be highly symbolic
if we are willing to be arrested and
have our freedom curtailed extinction
rebellion was founded in 2018 and claims
to have activists in around 50 countries
their protest method is civil
disobedience peaceful but sometimes
illegal and provocative to illustrate
the effects of climate change the
activists even died River in Switzerland
Green
the dye was harmless but the campaign
got a lot of attention and polarized
opinion the protesters have pitched
their tents in Berlin not just anywhere
but right in the heart of the government
district their expected roadblocks have
provoked mixed reactions from Berliners
I think it's bad we need to find a
sensible solution a broad consensus in
society is what we're after and
extremism doesn't help I don't know what
they're going to achieve apart from
creating more traffic which isn't very
climate friendly
they should do it it's not a problem we
need to do something about it don't we
extinction rebellion only released a
partial list of which parts of Berlin it
intends to shut down the protest will
last a week but for many the climate
fighters a long-term commitment Alice
who previously worked as a psychologist
has decided to live off her savings and
dedicate yourself full-time to the
campaign pursuing a career is becoming
more and more irrelevant if you look at
the broad context our work here is very
important so I can't imagine doing
anything else
at this moment [ __ ] America Lucca alles
dream is that soon governments around
the world will listen to her and her
peers and it's that goal that extinction
rebellion want to raise awareness for
over the coming days
Birgit this isn't the first time that
extinction rebellion has staged protests
in London
what do Londoners make of it well I've
been speaking to people that are passing
by this particular protest and
admittedly very randomly I have stopped
passers-by have stopped cyclists and my
opinion is my impression is that most
are broadly supportive particularly the
people who are cycling past this is a
very very it's a route that's used often
by cyclists in the morning in and out of
work one of the big sort of routes into
the city and the cyclists are very
supportive of the process however I've
also speaking to some others and one
lady said she she does understand where
they're coming from but on the other
hand they are blocking the routes and of
course London is a very busy city and
they are blocking major traffic arteries
and and they would also that would
hinder people also who are already
traveling in a greener way for example
by buses so some people do do object to
the mess that methods that's for sure
bigger thank you very much for now
that's big at mass force in London and
here in Berlin we had Simon Young our
political correspondent out on the
streets thank you to you thanks to you
both very much
and for more on the protest we're joined
by dr. claire wordly she says wall
artist and research associate at the
University of Cambridge and she's also
an active supporter of extinction
rebellion good to have you with us first
of all dr. wordly tell us in a nutshell
what extinction rebellion is and what
makes it different from other movements
like grete tune berg's Friday for future
thank you well to begin with of course
we share a lot of the same aims as
Fridays for future which is to get the
world to take serious action to get
governments to take action on climate
change and on other ecological crises
but with its Friday's for future this is
initially this is just schoolchildren
and this is there's not much role for
adults there other than coordinating so
with extinction rebellion this is
adults saying we don't just leave this
to the to the children we are also going
to protest and it's a grassroots
movement it's decentralized meaning that
anyone can if they abide by the
principles they can call themselves
extinction rebellion they can go
forwards we have a lot of connections
across all the different countries we
speak with each other but we're not for
example told what to do by the London
extinction rebellion or so on Berlin
takes its own actions and we make our
points by using civil disobedience okay
you this week your group of staging a
series of demonstrations all around the
world 60 cities I understand including
Berlin what are you hoping to achieve
with these actions so yeah so we've
already kicked off in Berlin with a
protest which started at 4:00 a.m. this
morning and we're hoping to do a variety
of things firstly to show the public how
absolutely serious these crises are I
think it's very easy to forget about
climate change and ecological collapse
because they're not very nice things to
think about we don't want to read about
them all the time and by disrupting we
bring it to the forefront of people's
attention we also bring it to the
forefront of governments attention and
show them that the people that the
citizens are not going to take this
lying down that we we want stronger
action that we have been trying for many
years to get this through different
means and the now the time has come
where we actually go out and we stand in
the streets and stay there until action
is taken so you're trying to draw
attention to the urgency of this the
language that you use it goes in the
direction of apocalypse we need to be
and something needs to be done now how
far given the urgency of it do you think
it's reasonable to push your agenda what
are the limits of civil disobedience for
you so for extinction rebellion as a
whole we have a set of guiding
principles one of those very important
principles is non-violence so we would
never say that violence in any form is
ever justified so we we remain within
the scope of non-violent actions so for
example this includes things like
roadblocks doing ourselves to particular
buildings or particular companies or
particular ministries or departments
and causing disruption but in a in a
quite usually quite a playful manner I'm
not causing any harm to any living thing
do you have faith in liberal democracy
in like we have here in Europe for the
most part to achieve the what you
believe is necessary in order to avoid
the collapse of our society in our
ecosystem it's a very interesting
question so I think one thing is that I
do have faith in democracy and I do
believe in democracy but I think that in
many cases our democracy has subverted
by special interest so if you look at
for example the influence of lobbyists
in the US oil and gas industries spent
over 120 million in 2018 alone lobbying
the government here in Europe we have
lobbyists from the oil and gas
industries from the coal industry from
the automobile industry and these
industries actually take rights away
from citizens so we see across Europe
most people want environmental
protections in the polls that have been
conducted and but I think that democracy
needs to be a true democracy and go back
more to the people and that's why
extinction rebellion calls for citizens
assemblies with randomly chosen citizens
informed by science to take decisions
thank you so much dr. claire wordly
she's with extinction rebellion she's a
zoologist a researcher at the University
of Cambridge thanks for being with us
this morning thank you very much